erwarten sie da heftige konflikte
mögliche ausschreitungen und die zweite
frage wenn wir sehen wie donald trump
gerade golf der hat noch ein foto
gemacht mit einem hochzeitspaar das dort
geheiratet hat erleben sie wie erleben
sie das glauben sie dass donald trump
wirklich bereit ist das weiße haus zu
verlassen oder wird er sich da irgendwie
an ein paar steine ketten und nicht
weggehen
naja irgendwann muss er weggehen sein
mietvertrag sozusagen läuft am 21 januar
aus und egal was er meint egal ob er
meint dass es ihm alles geklaut worden
ist ab dem 21
januar ist er hat er kein mietrechts
mehr kleinen bogen recht in dem haus und
dann musst ausgibt ist ohne frage die
größere frage ist ist das land so
gestalten dass das regieren nicht
möglich ist so da muss ich ehrlich sagen
in der amerikanischen presse aber auch
in der beschreibung in der deutschen
presse ist das etwas übertrieben
das ergebnis das beiden jetzt erreichen
wird wahrscheinlich höchstwahrscheinlich
ist sehr ähnlich wie ergebnisse wie es
über die letzten 40 oder mehr jahren
gegeben hat in amerikanischen
abstimmungen
er wird und sagte die höchste zahl der
stimmen bekommen aber das hat damit zu
tun dass die bevölkerung ab größe ist
aber noch dazu seinen 50 etwas prozent
ist sehr anständig und das 47 oder so
prozent das tram haben wird ist auch
anständig das zeigt nicht unbedingt dass
die gesellschaft polarisiert ist nur der
erste punkt zweitens natürlich es gibt
gerade bei den strom menschen sehr
starke hohe emotionen und das haben die
demokraten vernachlässigt in letzter
zeit die haben vernachlässig dass die
menschen die mit der globalisierung
nicht mitgekommen sind auch unterstützt
werden und auch verständnis für sie
gezeigt werden
das haben die demokraten total
verschätzt
trump an beiden malich der aus der
arbeiterklasse richtig aber der klasse
stammt er hat versucht das auch schon zu
regulieren
ein wahlkampf geführt hat hat sehr viel
in industriegebieten geredet er hat sehr
viel sympathie für die industrie
arbeiten gezeigt wie jetzt wenn sie dich
arbeitslos sind haben sie mindestens
anzug ihre arbeitsplätze
er hat angefangen um diesen fehler und
hoffentlich auch diesen reaktoren dass
wir lange dauern
die emotionen sind sehr haupt die
entfremdung von vielen menschen ist noch
sehr stark aber man sollte nicht sehen
dass auch die vereinigten staaten jetzt
unregierbar geworden ist mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaue ich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren